sur rose avec toi aussi tu recteur
ah merci
alors ça c'est une règle et ancestrale
quand on te dit je t'aime tu réponds
jamais par merci tous les êtres humains
de la planète se sont mis dans une pièce
pour se dire ok on dit pas merci tous
les noms ça m'étonnerait pas je sais pas
elle m'a sorti ça comme ça moi je ne m'y
attendais pas mais ça fait quatre mois
que tu mets ta langue dans sa bouche que
tu voulais qu'elle te dise je sais pas
c'est pas bien grave tu es amoureux tôt
sinon oui mais le jazz est toujours un
peu une étape tout c'est un truc naturel
moi chaque fois que je couche avec une
meuf lui dit je t'aime c'est au moment
de l'orgasme je peux pas m'en empêcher
c'est à dire pile pile au moment où
juste après le c'est un peu les deux
c'est genre ok on peut revenir à mon
histoire
oui dont tu lui as dit merci et leur
reste c'est parce que je voulais dire
non merci c'est gentil de ta part c'est
pas si facile
pas si facile ces trois mots non non
c'est plus deux mois et demi si tu
regardes bien tes apostrophe pas
vraiment un mot pour que pour qui c'est
tout mon ennemi ce qu'aime le tout le
plus facile du monde vous êtes marrants
l'a jamais dit aucune neuf mois mais
leur dit quoi du coup un mois aussi
carrément pas ça va un peu vite puisque
tu viens de dire
même chose c'est vraiment la meilleure
nounou caisse et nul n'est pas faire un
test vih à vous ou n'importe quel autre
mst à l'identique
[Musique]
ah ouais quand même
enfin bref pour en revenir alors elle
est entrée chez délires soirée là j'ai
plus de nouvelles bon bah écoute
s'inquiète pas déjà on va commander à
manger et à boire et à boire et puis re
trouver une solution et puis si on la
trouve pas bon on picole jusqu'à ce
qu'on ait oublié c'est sympa les gars
merci à fait normal on garde tél moi je
vous aime
ah ouais je t'aime tu m'as dit chut
ouais mais je crois que je pense est un
pote
[Musique]